so my very first job as a rookie was to
as soon as we got to Moo was to get
unstrapped out of my seat float down to
a locker by me get the proper camera out
float up to the overhead window while
dick Richards the commander on my first
flight was pitching Discovery over on
its back so that we could take a picture
of this tank it's following way back to
Earth well I floated up to the overhead
window and I'm looking outside and Dick
says hey Bruce you should be seeing it
and I said yeah dick I do it's awesome
it's beautiful he said well why aren't
you taking any pictures I said pictures
of what oh the tank I was so blown away
by seeing Earth for the first time that
I choked on my first job by the time I
took a picture of the tank it was like
falling away from us and and but it was
just beautiful it was just Ian just
seeing the Earth for the first time from
space is you know probably my most
memorable experience for the full story
watch the first episode of the insane
engineering of the space shuttle on our
Channel right now